for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
let's consider the following reaction
here from gluconeogenesis in which we're
converting pyruvate here into
oxaloacetate and in this reaction you
can see that a difference in structure
basically pyruvate had a carboxyl group
added to it to get this oxaloacetate and
that carboxyl group came from carbon
dioxide and this reaction requires ATP
and it's catalyzed by pyruvate
carboxylase so you might recognize this
reaction as a carboxylation reaction
because we're adding a carboxyl group
and it is more generally though it's a
reaction that involves a one carbon
transfer in this case the one carbon is
on carbon dioxide which is the most
oxidized that one carbon can be a one
carbon group can be so what who cares
right why am I saying this
well one carbon transfer reactions are
important in metabolism as we see here
but as well as in amino acid metabolism
and nucleotide metabolism so it's
important to kind of understand what's
going on with one carbon transfers okay
now when it comes to one carbon transfer
reactions there are three important
cofactors for those one carbon transfers
and these different cofactors differ
based on the oxidation state of the one
carbon group being transferred the first
cofactor for one carbon transfers that
we'll talk about is biotin biotin
specifically transfers carboxyl groups
as carbon dioxides
or you might see them as bicarbonate and
so biotin is important in carboxylation
reactions as we saw in this example up
here with pyruvate being converted to
oxaloacetate and if
and show it but there it is right there
biotin is important as a cofactor in
this reaction and so biotin isn't is
important because it transfers the most
oxidized one carbon unit or if you least
reduced depending on how you look at it
right that carbon dioxide that carbon
has four bonds to oxygen if you draw up
carbon dioxides lewis structure looks
like that right so four bonds to oxygen
that says that oxidized as a one carbon
group can be so biotin is important in
carboxylation reactions or transferring
one carbon groups in their most oxidized
form another important cofactor is
tetrahydrofolate or THF otherwise known
as tetrahydrofolate acid this guy
transfers a variety of one carbon groups
that are off often most of them are
intermediate li oxidized inter
immediately oxidized or intermediately
reduced again depending on how you look
at it it can transfer a methylene group
which looks like that transfer a formal
group which looks like that form an
amino groups methanol groups and even
methyl groups which are actually pretty
reduced okay now the last cofactor is
s-adenosyl methionine or Sam now Sam
transfers methyl groups which are of
course are just like this ch3 s and that
is the least oxidized most reduced a1
carbon group can be and so Sam is
important specifically in methylation
reactions okay you'll also notice here
that tetrahydrofolate transfers methyl
groups what's the deal with that well
that's something we'll get into in the
specific videos on each of these three
cofactors anyway I hope that video is
helpful in introducing one carbon
transfers thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying